We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two David Pakman.
Here's a very interesting voicemail. I realized
from looking at the email and looking at comments
about our vaccine related stories that this is
actually a confusion that a lot of folks have.
So listen to this then. I'll address it.
David Pakman. Big fan. Thank you.
Hey there. I have a question
about the daily vaccine count.
Yes, addresses, but I can't quite find an answer
when we say to point to two point three million
people vaccinated in one day.
Does that mean.
Two point two million shots, given that day,
does that mean two point two million people got
their second dose and now are fully vaccinated? So
I'm wondering if that is how that count is done.
Again, silly question. If you could just
either answer it on the show or the message,
but yeah, know the messages are good.
And this is this is a great question. We
are talking about doses. OK, so when we say
two point two million doses were given out,
that's a combination of first and second shots.
And take the Pfizer vaccine, for example,
which you have 21 days between shots. If today
or let me go backwards. Imagine that 21 days ago
we gave out 800000 Pfizer shots and then today
we give out one point five million Pfizer shots.
What that means is that today of the one point
five million Pfizer shots, eight hundred thousand,
if everything works right, 800000 per second doses
for people who got their first dose 21 days ago
and then 700000 would be first doses for people
who will get their second dose 21 days from now.
Right now, the approved vaccines in the United
States are two dose vaccines. So when we say
two million shots, we are talking about two
million total. But that's only half of the
vaccination protocol for each individual person.
They need a second shot soon. It looks like the
Johnson and Johnson vaccine is going to be
approved. That's a one shot vaccine. So in
the future, when we say, oh, we did three million
vaccines today, which would be a great number,
that might be a number of first and second doses
of the Pfizer vaccine, a number of first and or
second doses of the medicine, a vaccine, and then
a bunch of Johnson and Johnson doses, which are
the one sole dose since it will be a one dose.
So we are talking about doses, not people
totally vaccinated. The New York
Times is a good vaccine tracker,
which will tell you the total number of doses.
A number of people who have received one dose or
more, a number of people who have received full
to two dose regimens. And these numbers are all
going to be going up soon and we are going to
be tracking it. We have a great bonus show for
you today. We are going to talk about Joe Biden's
apparent snub of the Saudi crown prince, Mohammed
bin Salman. I find it very interesting and I
kind of like the direction Biden is going, going,
not go. He's not goading anybody going on Saudi
relations. We will talk about Facebook banning
Australian users from sharing or viewing news.
Why are they doing this? Very interesting story.
And we will also talk about Japan taking
action on this issue of social isolation,
appointing a minister of loneliness to help people
who are home alone. This is not just because of
the pandemic. This relates to issues that have
been happening culturally in Japan for some time,
which we've been talking about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Get Instant Access by becoming
a member at Join Pakman Dotcom.